hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others
happy to try and answer questions
um
and i see that
quite a few that have come in
uh to our form or are saved up from
previous weeks let me see what i can see
here
um
okay there's one from parmenides
asking what is quantum chemistry good
for anything interesting
all right let's talk about chemistry
i've been trying to learn about
chemistry recently
when i was a kid
i was really interested in physics and
quite a lot about physics
uh
i really didn't care about chemistry
because i thought it was all about
taking different white powders and
pouring them into liquids and
and um
uh
seeing what happened and nothing
interesting ever happened the most
interesting thing that ever happened i
think one chemistry experiment i was
doing
was uh i just mixed a bunch of random
things together
in a plastic container one of those
things was carbon tetrachloride i think
which dissolves plastic and so that was
exciting that was about the most
exciting thing that ever happened and i
couldn't really see why one would care
about chemistry
okay i've changed my mind
50 years later or whatever
and chemistry
is really very interesting because
it's
it's very
uh sort of precise and formal in a way
you've got molecules
and they have a certain structure
and they kind of interact with each
other
in
in ways that are very much like the ways
that we might write down sort of
equation like things to to and and they
are they they come out with very precise
results so let's talk a little bit about
about chemistry and what's involved in
chemistry and then we'll talk about
quantum chemistry and so on
so
in sort of a typical case
first question is you've got a molecule
and it has a bunch of atoms
and the atoms are
connected together
by
and usually characterize the connection
by
bonds
you've got let's say i don't know we've
got water h2o
that's
uh
an o for oxygen
and h2 two hydrogens
and so somehow
the uh uh those atoms stick together in
a certain way
a typical atom
well has a nucleus which has a bunch of
protons and neutrons in case of hydrogen
in the simplest cases just one proton is
the nucleus in the case of uh
uh oxygen it's um
uh let's see i think it's eight protons
eight neutrons is that right oxygen
sixteen i think that's right
um but that's what its nucleus is
and um
uh and then it has
a
uh usually it has uh uh the same
number of uh let's say let's count it
out hydrogen helium lithium really boron
carbon nitrogen oxygen yes it is eight
it's the eighth element which means it
has eight protons
and in its kind of uh
most ordinary state it has eight
electrons as well
um so you've got this oxygen atom
you've got two hydrogen atoms
and how do they get stuck together
they get stuck together by a fairly
complicated process
that involves kind of the exchange of
electrons between the hydrogens and the
oxygen
so-called covalent bonding
and
uh
the way the periodic table works the
table of elements
it kind of gives you an indication of
how many sort of uh how many electrons
are available for exchange
by different elements and that's
determined by the column of the periodic
table that things are on so oxygen
has some
uh
two such two such sort of available
electrons
and that's and that's what it sort of
exchanges with the hydrogens each of
which has one such exchangeable electron
that's a very approximate way of
describing it
and the sort of true quantum the true
story of that in the level of sort of
official physics is really quite
complicated
um and
the the picture that one usually has of
it in sort of elementary chemistry
is
something which is a
probably a decent approximation but one
has to understand it's an approximation
so
in reality
there is a whole elaborate calculation
of what the probability to find an
oxygen atom in this position hydrogen
atoms in this position and so on
but when you kind of think about it in
terms of elementary chemistry you say
there's an oxygen here and you can even
make it with balls and sticks and there
are two hydrogens sticking out at a
certain angle what is it 108 degrees or
something i forget for the water
molecule that the two hydrogens are are
connected at and you just make it in
terms of balls and sticks
in reality
it's a much more complicated story and
were you to be able to sort of look at a
water molecule um you can't do visible
light but where you to be able to kind
of observe a water molecule which you
can with with other frequencies of
electromagnetic radiation in principle
at least
you would see the thing wobbling around
all the time it wouldn't be in a fixed
position the elect the the the oxygen
the hydrogens wouldn't be in a fixed
position it would be wobbling around and
there'd be in fact it wouldn't even just
be wobbling around there would be
a kind of a uh just different
probabilities for the thing to have a
different a slightly different shape
so
that's um so this whole question about
given some atoms kind of what shape of
molecule do you get is a really
complicated question
for some of the comparatively light
elements
it's a reasonable approximation to say
that a given element has a certain
valence a certain number of essentially
sort of available bonds that that it can
connect to other um other kinds of atoms
with
that's a reasonable approximation
and
that's sort of the first approximation
but the true story is much more
complicated and i gather i didn't
actually know this until very recently
that um for the heavier elements even
this picture of having a fixed number of
bonds doesn't really work it's a more
complicated story of this whole cloud of
electrons rather than a definite
direction where it can connect to
another atom there's a sort of
complicated cloud of electrons and
certain probabilities of having atoms in
different uh different orientations
relative to the original atom and so on
so complicated story
but when you
uh kind of think about chemistry in
terms of this kind of ball and stick
type model you've just got atoms and
bonds
you can kind of represent molecules just
in terms of graphs or networks
so for example i don't know you could uh
represent um
and now i'm going to embarrass myself
with my poor chemistry but but um
um
uh the the sort of a simple class of
molecules are the the alkane molecules
which consist of uh a sequence of carbon
atoms in a in a chain
and then actually not necessarily a
chain the sequence of carbon atoms with
hydrogens kind of hanging off them um
and so you get things like methane
propane butane
um going up to hexane decaying things
like that so decane is
ten carbon atoms in a chain with
hydrogens hanging off it and you can
represent that just by this by this
graph that just shows a line of ten
carbon atoms and sometimes you don't
even draw the hydrogens but or you can
have these little sort of sprouts coming
off to represent the hydrogens or you
can have something like benzene which is
a hexagonal ring of carbon atoms and you
can represent that by this this graph
that is just the rig
and for all these different kinds of
molecules
that
uh are
connected together in the sort of
standard way with bonds and so on um you
can represent them by by graphs
like that
sometimes people say well there's an
extra piece the so-called
stereochemistry that is how the atoms
are really actually arranged in
three-dimensional space and that can get
kind of complicated
but in a first approximation you're just
looking at what is the connection by
bonds between these atoms
okay
so that's kind of the the the basic
structure of molecules now you might ask
how do you work out in more detail what
molecules are like
well first thing to understand is
molecules are not rigid molecules kind
of flop around all over the place
and if you for example
for example if two molecules collide
with each other
even if they they might just collide and
bounce off but they're still flopping
around because of that collision and it
takes them a while to kind of uh calm
down and stop flopping around
um
now
uh and and how do they calm down well
that's again a complicated process
because
um in
uh these molecules
uh well okay so the the sort of the
the way to say it sort of the official
way to say it is they're governed by
quantum mechanics
and
that means that
uh sort of
many aspects of how they behave are for
example quantized what that means is you
might say well this molecule it can be
deformed in any way i want i can just
twist it by some number of degrees and
it'll just be a
that'll be a possible
configuration of the molecule but that's
not quantum mechanics says that you
can't do that quantum mechanics says at
least if you want the molecule to be
sort of stable for a while to be that
way for a long time that it has to be in
one of a quantized collection one of a
discrete set of possible states
and so when i say something like well
the molecule is flopping around and then
it will gradually go down to a state
with maybe lower lower energy where it's
not flopping around as much that
transition has to happen by a definite
quantum event
like the emission of a photon the
emission of a quantum of light or a
quantum of uh
infrared
light or something like that
um to make that transition
but the other issue is okay so you've
got this collection of atoms and you ask
the question well how would they connect
to each other how would they uh you know
how would that water molecule you know
you've got a an oxygen and a couple of
hydrogens and you put put them together
and how will they form into a water
molecule
well that's a pretty hard thing to
calculate there are mathematical
equations that uh sort of give you
information about that but those
equations get really hard to solve and
by the time you've got more than like
100 atoms
to solve those equations from scratch
and just say i throw these atoms in what
configuration will they end up in is
completely undoable at the present time
you have to sort of approximate that by
saying well
we know roughly how these atoms are
arranged maybe we can tweak it a little
bit using these fancy equations but we
have to know sort of roughly how the
things are arranged with the sort of
what the what the what the rough
arrangement of atoms is
and
another thing that's that's really
complicated is this
the um
uh
you might say
let's see how to think about this
uh all right so
in
in ordinary classical mechanics that
we're used to in the everyday world
we always imagine that sort of definite
things happen let's say you have
a uh a thing you've suspended on a
spring the things sort of bouncing up
and down according to you know in
gravity it's going up and down
and it and the the ball at the end of
the spring is in a definite place it
goes up it goes down it goes up it goes
down you know where it is
okay that's our common experience of the
world
but when you go to very very small
objects
what sort of takes over is this idea of
quantum mechanics and in quantum
mechanics you don't have this picture
that sort of definite things happen
instead there's the picture that there
are many many possible things that can
happen in fact in some sense every
possible thing can happen
but
in the end you can work out
uh and so sort of inside the quantum
mechanics all those different things are
happening in our models of physx we can
see this very explicitly
you basically see
all these possible paths of history for
the universe all those paths are getting
followed
and then the real question is well in
some sense intrinsically all those paths
are being followed and sometimes
there'll be a path where two different
things can happen sometimes those two
different things can merge because they
both end up in the same configuration
later on etc so there's all these
branching emerging cards that are all
possible histories for the universe and
so the question that they always
question to ask is well if that's what's
going on how come we think that definite
things are happening well that's a
really tricky thing
because part of that story is that we
are part of that universe that is
branching and merging branching and
emerging and so on so our brains are
also branching and merging so quantum
mechanics becomes the story of how does
a sort of branching brain perceive a
branch of the universe that's a
complicated thing and i'm still trying
to wrap my brain fully around that idea
slowly trying to get analogies of that
and so on and and really try to try to
internalize what it means to have this
kind of notion of sort of the branching
brain that perceives a definite thing to
have happened
and uh
it's a um that's a
i've sort of one of the things that we
humans do
is we generally think that we have a
definite thread of experience we think
that a definite sequence of things
happen in our life and in the world and
so on and what quantum mechanics is sort
of saying is that well that's just how
we are putting together all these
branches
and maybe there's even sensors in which
you know one's brain when one sort of
doesn't know what's going on one's
surprised about something one just
imagining all these different things
that could be going on that that's kind
of a a little bit of a hint about what
it's like to not have
uh you know knitted together a thread of
experience it's like something weird
happened and i don't i haven't yet put
together what it was that happened
and that's a little bit like maybe
what's going on when when we have
quantum mechanics and when we turn all
of that sort of all those threads of
history into the definite one thread of
experience that we think we have
okay what does this have to do with
molecules well in this idea that sort of
everything happens and then eventually
you find out what happened
by perceiving it in some way how does
that relate to molecules well in this
molecule so if everything is happening
then what sense does it make to have the
definite picture of the ball and stick
and the and the water molecule that has
this particular shape and so on how can
that make any sense
okay this is not an easy question to
answer
and this relates to
the question of what we really
think of about how quantum mechanics
works
in the most basic mathematical models of
quantum mechanics
which quantum mechanics was invented
originally in the 1920s by the 1930s
there were kind of very precise
mathematical characterizations of
quantum mechanics which mostly say
there's all this quantum stuff that
happens and all these many many
possibilities that go on and then
there's this phenomenon of measurement
and that takes all those many
possibilities for what's going on and
then kind of the the sort of the hammer
comes down
and
something and and we decide that
something definite happened
and
which way things come out there may be a
certain probability we may not know
which of those things will come out when
a particular you know when we when the
hammer comes down a particular time we
may not know we only may be able to say
there's a there's a one-third chance
that does this a two-thirds chance it
does that um but there's a definite
hammer comes down you go from all this
quantum stuff going on inside to the
definite measurement result that's the
traditional view of quantum mechanics
that's the kind of mathematical
structure that's been built up to think
about quantum mechanics
okay well let's talk about a molecule
it's a bit of a trickier situation
because
that molecule it's not as if you let the
molecule the
in some sense what seems to be happening
is that there is continual measurement
of the molecule that somehow
the environment the chemical environment
that the molecule finds itself in is
somehow doing the equivalent of
continually making measurements
continually making the hammer come down
just a bit
and and that's why
it's that's why even though at the
quantum mechanical level sort of all
things are happening all simultaneously
together all these different threads of
history that somehow in chemistry for
reasons not well understood
the the sort of chemical environment is
playing the role of a sort of very
microscopic version of something like
the the sort of the measuring process
the human observer who is deciding that
definite things happened and so on
somehow chemistry is doing that at a
sort of at a continual microscopic level
and that's kind of why we can say that a
molecule has a definite form even though
it's operating
according to quantum effects again this
isn't completely understood and i think
there's probably some rather interesting
science as one sort of unravels this
particularly with our new
interpretations of quantum mechanics and
so on but okay so so this bit of a
mystery that it's possible to have
uh you know a definite form of a
molecule even though there's quantum
mechanics going on
um but then we can start asking okay
uh
you know if we if we buy into well that
molecule has a definite form
is there sort of extra wigglings around
that come about because of quantum
mechanics the answer is
is yes and we can calculate some of that
it's pretty difficult to calculate we
can calculate some of that
uh even for the case of water water is
an unbelievably complicated thing
and uh you know in in liquid water for
example you might say well water is h2o
okay we know that that means every
molecule of water is just an oxygen two
hydrogens you say in a liquid all these
water molecules are just sort of
bouncing around they keep on colliding
with each other they keep on bouncing
off and they just sort of randomly
arranged well it's not true
in water there's clearly in liquid water
there's all kinds of structure there's
all kinds of clusters of water molecules
that are all sort of connected i think
they're these things that get called
proton highways where you can have kind
of a um a bunch of water molecules all
kind of lined up and you can start sort
of transporting electrons from molecule
to molecule things like this
and
it's it's a water is an extremely
complicated substance and it has a uh so
when you look at it microscopically uh
in a liquid form for example it's got
all these different sort of uh
patterns of molecules that are forming
just for a moment
just for
uh times like
on the order of femtoseconds some
a a thousand trillionths of a second um
they're forming they're breaking apart
they're forming again they're breaking
apart
that's kind of the structure in liquid
water and it has
all kinds of features about that
the uh
knowing why the boiling point of water
is what it is you can kind of calculate
the forces between water molecules you
get a completely different answer from
the actual boiling point of water the
actual extent to which water can start
uh sort of throwing off you know go from
the liquid state to break the molecules
apart to make steam um happens at i
think a much lower temperature than you
would expect
from um just calculating the forces
between the molecules and so on
so
that's a case where we still don't
really know why water has all the
characteristics it has particularly in
its liquid phase now to talk a little
bit more about chemistry
the
uh sort of the the main thing that kind
of happens in chemistry be along the
level of individual molecules is
reactions between molecules
well what what's going on in in a the
most the place where the most reactions
happens in liquids in solids the um uh
you have
molecules or atoms arranged in this
regular kind of typically crystalline
type way so they're all in their place
and they're not sort of able to collide
with each other and and make changes
they're pretty much all in their place
um not not always but but that's the
most common case
in a gas
yes there are molecules always bouncing
around but the density of molecules is
comparatively low and and so it isn't as
um
you if if those molecules let's say the
molecules are they're always colliding
with each other they they go around a
tiny distance in in typical pressure of
gas like a in
in you know
in the air in the atmosphere they're
going only a very tiny distance
molecules go in a tiny distance before
they collide with other molecules but
the
most of the time those collisions are
elastic in the sense that molecule
collides with another molecule the
molecules stay together and they're not
they don't fall apart they don't start
exchanging atoms or electrons or
anything like that they just they just
bounce off each other
um
so if you are going to have a chemical
reaction happens when the two molecules
collide but instead of just bouncing off
each other they do some complicated
thing they change their shape they
exchange atoms they
their bonds get smooshed and break apart
and they get reconnected somewhere else
and so on
and
just
in order to have that happen they're
just vastly more collisions that happen
in liquid so that's the place where the
the it's more common to have chemical
reactions and then the whole question of
sort of how those chemical reactions
work
and when the molecules hit the
particular angles they need to be
hitting at the right angle for the
reaction to happen and so on
one of the things and i think maybe i've
talked about this before but but there
are i'm steadily learning more about
this
the um
one of the biggest uses when you're
going to have a reaction between two
molecules is do they hit at the right
angle do they hit so that the particular
piece of that molecule sticks into this
hole in the other molecule and the atoms
can exchange their bonds and things like
this or not
and so one way to have that happen is to
have a catalyst that is something like a
metal that's a surface and one molecule
will kind of get get embedded in the
surface and kind of expose itself in a
particular direction and then another
molecule will come and be able to stick
itself in in that direction instead of
so one molecule is fixed and that means
only the other molecule has to be in the
right configuration where otherwise
rather than both of them having to be uh
sort of happen to be in the right
orientation
and
when it comes to biology one of the
things biology has
become very expert at is arranging
molecules to be in the right orientation
and the right place to actually have
reactions and so enzymes the catalysts
that get used in life mostly proteins
are arranged to have all these kind of
holes and crevices and places where one
molecule will attach itself in this way
and expose itself in just the right way
that another molecule can come in and
have a chemical reaction with it
and and life even does much more
elaborate things it even has all of
these tubes that uh are in the the sort
of the cytoskeleton this the sort of
internal fibrous fibrous skeleton of
biological cells that are actually
moving molecules around they're just
moving them down like a like a train
track um so that the molecules end up in
the right place at the right time to
have a chemical reaction
so that that's that's a little bit on so
so in some sense
the uh when we talk about for example a
liquid phase reaction
we're talking about you know molecules
and liquid they're bouncing around
they're reacting with each other
uh in biology it's almost like a biology
phase reaction because it's almost like
there's there's there are all these
enzymes and and microtubules and all
this kind of thing which are kind of
more machine-like ways moving molecules
around so that they can undergo
reactions
and there was a there was an enthusiasm
in the
uh 1980s i guess particularly for
early kind of nanotechnology and
molecular manufacturing and kind of the
idea there was could you take things
that we know
from sort of traditional mechanical
devices and could you shrink them down
and implement them with individual
molecules and sort of make what one
might think of as sort of a machine
phase where instead of it being liquids
where the molecules are bouncing around
randomly or solids where all the
molecules are arranged you know in a
very regular way something where there's
sort of an intentional
machine-like arrangement of the
molecules where there's you know cogs
and levers and things like that and you
might say what a bizarre idea to make
uh
you know make gearing for example out of
molecules but actually that's something
that happens
in uh in the little tails the flagella
of bacteria and things you'll find these
these sort of motors that are made with
kind of a fixed gearing i think maybe
they have 13 uh
13 sort of teeth on the cog type thing
um in in certain cases and so so that
idea of sort of making mechanical stuff
out of uh making our traditional
mechanical stuff like gears and so on
out of molecules
it's it's something one can imagine
doing whether that's the best way to
make use of molecules to achieve things
we want to achieve that's a different
question in traditional chemistry that's
not what one's usually doing just saying
throw these molecules together they will
react you can think about it as this
graph plus this graph will be
reconfigured into that other graph if i
if i thought about it that way
sort of 50 years ago when i was learning
about chemistry i probably would have
been much more enthusiastic about
chemistry um instead of just uh you have
you memorize these kinds of this white
powder and that white powder gives this
other white powder um the uh
more interesting
at least to uh to somebody like me is
this idea that you can
just like we can write down like a
mathematical expression you know x
squared plus one and that's a definite
kind of abstract thing that we can do
things to we can also say well we can
write down this graph that represents a
chemical and we can do definite things
to that graph
so for example just like we can
transform we can say we've got x squared
plus one we can replace x by x plus two
or something and see what we get or you
can do very much the same kind of thing
in a molecule you've got this graph it's
got some some piece of the graph there
that might be just a single atom or it
might be a collection of atoms you could
say let's replace that piece of the
graph by something else by another piece
of graph
and and that's essentially what happens
in chemical reactions is there's a
replacement of one piece of graph by
other pieces of graph and so on and and
that's a very sort of formal way to
think about it it's not precisely
correct
actual molecules are sort of floppier
and more complicated than that
but it's a good first approximation and
there's lots of kind of reasoning that
you can do at that abstract level and
that's
kind of a lot of what people learn in
learning things like organic chemistry
and so on
so uh you know i think that that's um
uh but but the thing that you know in a
traditional sort of chemistry setting
it's like molecules are just
rolling around randomly and they might
happen to connect with each other when
we start thinking about um
kind of machine-like situations which is
what biology has managed to to set up in
many cases it's much more like this
molecule it's going to be made in this
place it's going to be moved along this
kind of conveyor belt by other molecules
it's going to be set up to do this it's
going to be connected into this other
molecule this will happen et cetera et
cetera now an interesting question is
that sort of story of there's a machine
and it operates this way the fact that
we can tell such a story
is it's not obvious that that's the only
thing that's going on in the chemical
system it could be that there is some
such story to be told and maybe biology
has tried to arrange it so that that's a
an important story but there's probably
more to it there's probably more that's
at the level of the kinds of things that
quantum mechanics talks about even
though it might not operate according to
quantum mechanics itself where there are
many possible paths for how this
molecule can be oriented and can react
with other ones and so on and that
becomes
a a much more difficult thing to analyze
and it's something for which we don't
have very good sort of human narrative
description capabilities but it's
something where i suspect that that's
going to be important in understanding
how one can for example do computations
efficiently with molecules and such like
um
the
let's see
okay there's a question here about
um
uh
commenting on chemistry but amenities is
commenting about how great chemistry is
and how important it is
um
to the world for sure it's it's you know
molecules are our raw material and
chemistry is our way of manipulating
molecules
maybe eventually we will have a much
more sophisticated way of manipulating
molecules right now it's it's just you
throw these buckets of molecules
together and you hope they react rather
than this much more structured
programmable way of having molecules
interact where you really sort of know
what orientation the molecule is in and
you know what it's going to do
and so on uh you know eventually one
might have a situation where one can
really have what we might think of as
programmable matter
where you say here's this thing
and i can really specify just like on a
computer i can tell it do a different
computation
and
i can just feed it in a program to say
fixed hardware just do a different
computation
one might imagine that that same kind of
thing would one day happen for molecules
and matter that one would be able to say
okay you've got a you've got a
collection of molecules here we've got
this whole we've got molecules et cetera
et cetera i feed in a program you know i
flash light at the thing or something in
some complicated pattern of flashes and
the thing says okay i understand that
program now i'm going to configure
myself in this or that way at the level
of molecules in other words that you
might be able to program the the actual
operation and structure of matter
something i've been curious about for a
long time could you make a machine that
would just make any molecule you give it
a drawing of the molecule and you say go
and make this molecule usually when
people think about synthetic chemistry
their way of making a molecule is some
very elaborate thing where oh you have
to you know if you throw in this kind of
molecule then it will lop off this arm
that's on that other molecule oh but you
don't want it to cut out this little
piece in the middle so you have to put
in a protecting group on the molecule to
stop it having to stop the other
molecule you throw in
being able to get at that part of the
molecule you don't want to get at then
you do this then you send in some other
molecule to get rid of the protecting
group but it's kind of a whole sort of
puzzle story whereas one could think
that one day it would be really a
question of just you have this molecule
you have the soup and you're basically i
don't know how you communicate with that
soup you know in the case of a computer
uh it's we we kind of you know we're
just using electrical signals um uh that
are that are very so precisely arranged
to do what they do i don't know how you
can communicate with your kind of super
molecules particularly well it probably
wouldn't actually be in a liquid phase
it'd probably be in some kind of weird
machine phase where the molecules are
dynamic and in fact my guess is what it
would be is in a standard solid the
molecules are just lined up like in a
crystal they're just all lined up in a
particular configuration in a glass for
example also pretty much a solid the
molecules are there but they're all sort
of stuffed in randomly just like some
you know ball pit or something where
you've thrown a bunch of balls in
randomly but they're still all jammed
together
well one can imagine a phase of matter
in which i should i should say in a
liquid obviously the molecules are kind
of running around they don't get very
far they collide with other molecules
but they're they're basically uh you
know they're basically randomly uh
running around
so you could imagine a phase of matter
in which
the molecules aren't fixed in place but
they have complicated little you know
dances that they do where you know the
thing is is reconfiguring itself locally
and it just the molecules are moving
around um but it is still a quite
orderly thing and the molecules that
let's say in this in their steady state
the molecules are all doing some kind of
weird little figure eight dances with
each other with neighboring molecules
and that's happening throughout the
material and then then you kind of flash
light at it and suddenly they they
change their figure eight configurations
and they they start going to neighboring
molecules and they start implementing a
different kind of rule for operation one
could imagine i i remember thinking
about this actually
oh 40 years ago now um of whether one
could make one of these cellular
automata that i've studied a lot where
you just have a collection of cells and
each cell is updated according to a
fixed rule depending on the values of
its neighbors could you make that out of
individual molecules
and could you for example have something
where there is dynamical it's a it's a
continuously kind of molecular scale
moving thing
and you know your flashlight at it or
use some electrical signal of some kind
and it changes it's the rule that it's
using to determine how those molecules
sort of move around
uh that would be kind of a version of
programmable matter
and it will be a very weird thing we
don't know how to make that kind of
thing yet
um and you know
potentially with programmable matter
like that you could have it you know
reconfigure itself in all kinds of ways
but maybe it starts at the level of
molecules but then it builds itself up
to something which is a large scale kind
of walking creature or something i know
there are science fiction movies that
have kind of effects that look a bit
like that and one can imagine that that
might actually be possible in practice
to have something where one can sort of
determine how the things work down to
the level of molecules um and that's but
that's that's not our current state of
the art in chemistry our current state
of the art is to make things you have to
really do this kind of very
indirect thing of throwing things in and
hoping that they interact in the right
ways
um
i think uh
this issue about sort of what might be
possible if we could do things at a
molecular scale i mean right now with
computers we know the amazing power of
being able to program things being able
to have a one fixed piece of computer
hardware that you can program to do all
these different kinds of things if we
could do that with mata down at the
level of individual molecules we will be
able to do spectacularly more things
and i think that the um
the question of um
uh
the only case that we have right now
where things are sort of happening at
the level of molecules and sort of where
there's essentially computational level
of molecules is what's happening in
biology but if we could generalize
biology to arbitrary things with
programmable matter uh spectacular kinds
of technology might will would be
possible um it would sort of potentially
it will put biology to shame so to speak
in the sense that biology has proudly uh
progressed for a few billion years sort
of sl slowly through biological
evolution tweaking to get a little bit
better at doing this or that thing
um if we start thinking about kind of
the
uh the picture of well if we could just
program anything at the molecular scale
what could we program to have happen
that's an interesting question and i
don't know it would be interesting to
think through
what would be some of the first
technological wow moments for being able
to do that kind of thing i think some of
the ones that we would care the most
about
are ones that interface with us humans
and interface with the biology that we
have and the molecular biology that we
have and sort of are saying well don't
use you know you've got organs that do
molecular scale filtering of things in
your body or whatever else you know
that's a goofy way to do it here there's
a better way to do it that you can make
with sort of programmable matter and
that you can interface to the existing
uh biological structures that you have
so
i noticed that uh perennities was
commenting on the the effect of
chemistry on history of of humanity and
obviously it's very great i think
what are the estimates you know uh
if it was some
if we didn't have you know agriculture
and all those kinds of things
um if we hadn't figured out how to
optimize those things the earth might
support 10 million people and that's
about it
um and uh you know we're at nearly 8
billion and counting so to speak and
that's kind of a big effect of well both
theories of you know principles of
agriculture and chemistry and things
like fertilizer and so on
um and i think that that uh uh it is an
interesting question
um
uh sort of uh you know just being able
to feed people is one big effect of
chemistry uh you know other things that
have happened in chemistry that are
really important i suppose are well lots
of industrial processes for making
things you know you have uh whether it's
um whether it's going and going from
sort of the ore of rocks that have a few
atoms here and there of iron or aluminum
or something like that to actually his
here's a big block of aluminum that's
another kind of chemistry-like process
um two kinds of things where
uh we're
doing well
making uh you know for example uh one
thing that was sort of important 100
years ago or so now was plastic you know
the fact that one could just make a
completely new kind of material that was
uh useful for different purposes it
wasn't made of wood it wasn't made of uh
you know it wasn't made of metal it was
something where one had for the first
time arranged these long molecules
that's what plastic is made of created
these long molecules and made them into
a material that one could sort of create
from scratch
um that's that was sort of the the
remarkable thing that that was plastic
and there are obviously other kinds of
um well there are other kinds of sort of
new materials that ones to do with
uh carbon nanotubes and things like that
which are possible which might be
significant now
but i think one of the things that sort
of the ultimate thing is the
programmable version of mata where well
instead of it being just this fixed
arrangement of a molecule it's something
where it has a continual sort of
choreography inside um and is where
that's specifiable in some external kind
of way and that becomes sort of a quite
new level of um sort of generalized
chemistry sort of a combination of
computation and chemistry that uh i
think has some uh sort of interesting as
i say to to imagine what becomes
possible in that situation i i think as
i say the the sort of the interface for
biology will be pretty important i also
suspect
that um oh you know people have talked
for a long time like you know can you
grow a house
um could you imagine i mean people have
these sort of ideas of you know if we
could manipulate biology more um we
could instead of having a house where
you have to actually construct it and
you've got you know pieces of wood that
you make from dead trees and things like
this
imagine that you could have something
where you've got sort of a biological
organism that is arranged to grow in the
shape of a house
um and uh you know could you do that
and you could imagine if you have
programmable matter that instead of sort
of piggybacking on the back of oh you
know
uh sort of the biologically growing
house where you have the problem of oh i
didn't feed my house enough today um
it's uh you know it's an it's in a bad
mood type thing
i think one would have all kinds of well
um whatever it's it's some uh you know
piggybacking on top of biology that one
could imagine something with a sort of
truly programmable matter where you
could say okay i mean
another thing that is the case is that
that right now yeah this is probably the
most significant thing that right now
you make something you manufacture it
it's a certain shape
maybe you have a
dye
that you use to um uh you know you pour
plastic into a into a dye um you know
you mold it in a certain shape it uh
it's maybe it's liquid when it starts
out it cools down then it's this plastic
thing that's this shape
or something where you're connecting
together these rods and you're welding
them together or whatever else it's a
definite shape the things we have right
now
most
sort of manufactured things
are well they're kind of definite shapes
maybe they have levers and and gears and
so on that can move but they're
basically a definite shape but imagine
in a world where you're dealing with
programmable matter you get this blob
and the blob you just you know you take
it home and it's just well you probably
wouldn't have to do that even everybody
would have lots of these blobs of
programmable matter you take the blob of
programmable matter out you flash its
program at it and pretty soon it
reconfigures itself
and then it's a
uh you know it's a paperweight or it's a
um
uh or it's a thing you know
a hair brush or it's a whatever else it
is
um and that all happens as a uh you know
it's managed to configure itself
by just moving its molecules around
under program control so to speak
and i think that's a uh sort of the kind
of thing one can imagine in this sort of
chemistry meets computing uh future in
that in that case
um
i think
the thing then becomes an issue is okay
you're making this thing but maybe this
thing needs
uh you know iron atoms in it maybe it's
a thing that has some needs some
properties that require a particular
kind of atom so then you have to have
the supply of different kinds of atoms
and it's an interesting question to what
extent most of the things that we care
about happen with objects
um are actually more about the shapes of
those objects and their mechanical
properties or maybe their electrical
properties than they are about really
are they made of aluminum or iron or
whatever else
and and that is it possible that the
sort of programmable matter that it's
just carbon and hydrogen and and
you know oxygen let's say and that's it
and that you can kind of get everything
you want just made in terms of those
those elements that sort of part of the
story of plastic
is um
is that you really are using mostly
those elements to make things um and you
can sort of configure them in lots of
different ways
um and so that will be a question is
whether you know in in the case of i
don't know transporting oxygen in our
blood we use hemoglobin which is mostly
the sort of cage that's a protein but
inside that cage is this little hole in
which there's an iron atom and that iron
atom is important for the way that our
hemoglobin works to transport oxygen
around our blood but i don't know if
that's actually necessary or whether
there's some way of having the same
effect with exactly the right
configuration of carbon carbon and
oxygen atoms making the right kind of
cage the right kind of sort of tube that
lets oxygens through and and so on uh so
i don't know to what extent
the it is necessary i mean we we have
available to us elements other than
let's say carbon hydrogen oxygen but i
don't know to what extent that's truly
necessary to achieve the things that we
want to achieve it's sort of an
interesting question if you have a
computer that
we kind of now know that you can make a
universal computer out of very simple
components you don't need all of the
complicated circuitry you can make it
out of just some simple set of rules
uh in chemistry one might have imagined
when you at least need all kinds of
atoms the whole periodic table but maybe
that isn't true maybe if what you're
trying to do is is for many purposes
that we might define as the purposes for
which we want to use matter we actually
don't need all those other kinds of
atoms we can achieve those things by the
appropriate configuration by the
appropriate programming of just let's
say carbon hydrogen oxygen
um
woman is saying this isn't organic
chemistry the study of programmable
matter well the distinction that i'm
making is
that
in chemistry
you're not
able to at the level of an individual
molecule just tell it go do this
you're having to do that very indirectly
by smashing molecules into each other
and so on
uh
let's see maybe one more
um
let's see
aaron is asking
can you tell the story of traveling
through a central processing union on
the computer from the electrons
perspective
interesting
well
interesting
so the first thing to explain is
electricity is a flow of electrons
but
so
in a metal for example
there is
a metal has a bunch of atoms
of that metal let's say copper something
like that
um
and those atoms are arranged in an array
and a crystal
and those atoms have certain electrons
which are very tightly bound to the
nuclei of the atoms and they're not
going anywhere
but what happens in a metal is that some
of the outer electrons that are further
away from the nucleus
they end up being sort of there's an
overlap between
neighboring atoms and eventually you
form what's called the conduction band
where
essentially the electrons that are sort
of that far away from their nucleus
aren't bound closely enough to any one
nucleus and so they're able to float
float freely through the metal and so
that's that's kind of what leads to the
fact that a metal can conduct
electricity is that the electrons are
not not attached
some of the electrons are not so tightly
attached to their individual atom um
they're able to just float from from
atom to atom in this conduction band
that's kind of how things work
in a typical metal
and your
your uh the electrons as they as they
flow through the crystal they're usually
the reason they don't flow
completely freely is that there are uh
they keep on um as an electron is kind
of moving through the through the
crystal it keeps on running into things
it keeps on bumping into oh there's an
atom in the way oh there's there's this
kind of imperfection in the crystal
there's these different things it keeps
on
having uh being scattered so the
electron let's say let's say when you
put a voltage
on a wire what the voltage is doing is
it's putting making an electric field
that will pull electrons through the
wire but the electrons don't just whiz
through the wire at some maximum speed
um
the they they keep on getting scattered
by things they keep the electron is
being pulled by the electric field but
it keeps on hitting something and then
it scatters away
and and that process of scattering is
what leads to resistance
resistivity of materials
that's the the thing that makes it be
the case that when you put a certain
voltage on the wire the current the the
flow of electrons through the wire is
only there's only a limited flow of
electrons through the wire so there's
this formula v equals ir ohm's law
um or put it a different way i the
current the rate of flow of electrons is
voltage divided by r and so that's
telling you that as there's more
resistance there's less current and the
resistance is the amount of scattering
that happens in these electrons
so so what's going on is the electrons
they're being pulled through the wire
but they keep on running into things and
the amount they run into things depends
for example on the temperature of the
wire so as you decrease the temperature
they will tend to be
less sort of random stuff going on in
the wire so the electrons will flow a
bit more freely there's a phenomenon
that happens at very low temperatures a
few degrees above absolute zero at
absolute zero it's sort of in the first
approximation all this running around
that molecules do that defines
temperature more or less stops at
absolute zero but there are particular
materials called superconductors
where electrons do flow freely through
the material they don't get scattered by
anything they can just zoom right
through so they have essentially zero
resistance
um they have sort of infinite well
um that's not quite
they have um yeah they have let's just
say they have zero resistance and
electrons can move you can like have
electrons that you put them in a loop in
a kind of wire of superconductor and
they just keep going around for months
and months
if you and whereas in an ordinary wire
at ordinary uh they would be uh the
electrons would kind of be stopped by by
um uh by
by collisions and by resistance by
resistivity okay so that's how an
ordinary wire works
um a semiconductor so so
the
uh
in a metal
there is a conduction band there are
some electrons which are delocalized
they are not localized to individual
atoms
in an insulator something which doesn't
conduct electricity
you have a situation where
where essentially the electrons are
closely bound to every atom so you can't
tear an electron even if you put a big
electric field on the material you can't
the electrons will just be stuck they're
not moving they're just stuck to an atom
they don't move they might move a tiny
bit away from their atom but they don't
get to jump to the positions of other
atoms at least not until you put a huge
electric field and then you have a
breakdown of the material that's what
lightning strikes are and things like
that
but normally in an insulator electrons
are just bound to their atoms okay
there's an intermediate case which is
semiconductors
and in the semiconductor
the electrons are basically bound to
their atoms
but there is a certain what's called
band gap
if you put a certain voltage
on the uh on the material you'll be able
to promote an electron
from
this uh from its sort of tightly bound
configuration into the conduction band
if you give it enough energy it'll start
sort of flowing freely through the
material in the case of silicon the band
gap is six volts
and so if you put that's why a lot of
electronics runs on you know six volt
batteries and things nine volt batteries
things like that
is because that's what you need to get
the electrons promoted into the
conduction band and so sort of the big
idea in and i'm lighting a whole bunch
of stuff here but but the more or less
the big idea
in of using semiconductors is that you
can kind of switch on and switch off
uh conduction by by whether you're
promoting these electrons or not the way
it really works there is uh this idea of
doping where you put other materials
other um
into semiconductors and that changes
where the conduction band is it's a
slightly longer story but
in the end in a in a cpu
the um uh
the the sort of the key element of these
sensible fetal field effect
transistors and they're made from
semiconductors and essentially what
happens is they have um
uh it's called the source and the drain
you're basically you have a source of
electrons and they're sort of going
towards the the drain and there's a
thing the gate which is another sort of
wire that goes across so there's sort of
like a wire going one direction in this
field effect transistor
and then there's another wire that goes
90 degrees across it
and that that other wire when you put
a
voltage
on that sort of that gate you can
determine whether a current will flow
from the source to the drain
and that that switchability that's the
key piece of functionality needed to
make a uh electronic circuit
and when you put a billion of those
together you get a modern microprocessor
um and the the design of exactly how
those those uh those field effect
transistors those switches are put
together that's the thing that you have
to kind of um uh you can start talking
about logic operations the the most
basic operation that is done by one of
those field effect transistors is either
a nand or a nor operation basically
saying if you've got two inputs
and if it is not the case
that both of the inputs are
have a voltage effectively
then um then have an output voltage but
otherwise don't and that operation if
you put together nand gates you can make
all the standard logic operations and
you can create the things that you need
to make a microprocessor
okay so at the most basic level of
electrons things are happening where the
electrons are being promoted into the
conduction band
by and then they're they're dropping
down from that and they're being stuck
somewhere and it's kind of a i think
from an electron's point of view it's
kind of a lot of stop start type stuff
of oh this circuit uh this wire started
having a voltage on it okay now we can
go i'll move on to the next place i'll
move on to the next gate
um and then i'll um uh i'll go and about
by the way the whole sort of assembly um
of of that makes an and or an aura or
nand or something that's usually called
the gate i guess i've never even noticed
the confusion of the fact that a single
component of a field effect transistors
is also called a gate but they're a
little bit different they're ultimately
contributing to the same thing with a
little bit different in detail but in
any case the so from an electron's point
of view i think you're kind of moving
through wires but you keep on stopping
restarting etc now you know it's a
little bit of a a philosophical issue
are you the same electron when you after
you've got stopped and you get stuck to
an atom for a while and then you start
moving again are you the same electron
or not and that's certainly a sort of
philosophical question of uh uh which
you know at the level of a human
there's enough pieces of us that the
fact that we might be being recreated as
we move through space is is we still
think of ourselves as definitely us but
if it's a single electron that's getting
stopped and then restarted again it's a
little bit less clear because all
electrons seem to be identical
it's a little bit less clear whether we
would say it's the same electron but
let's just for for poetic purposes let's
say it's the same electron that's
getting stopped at some gate it's going
to start again it's going to move
as voltages change things happen
so what is what is going to happen on a
typical electron so
uh the power supply of your computer
is like generating voltage it's pushing
out electrons in this current and those
electrons are going in
and some of those electrons will be used
to uh
some of that that current is going to go
to the cpu
um the central processing unit
and um
let's pick a thing that an electron
might be doing well gosh as it comes in
actually it's kind of an interesting way
to think about it i mean the the
what will happen is as the electrons
come in
they'll be sort of shunted to different
places
to um
to do different kinds of things and i
think that shunting
is basically going to happen at random
depending on so so for example let's say
we've got a wire coming in and it splits
in two
which way is the electron going to go is
it going to go left or right
i think that's going to be pretty much
uh just randomly determined that is the
electron there's nothing about that
particular electrons can say i'm a left
i'm one that's going to go down the left
branch i'm going to
go down one's going to go with the right
branch but what's going to happen is
it's kind of like it's kind of like
maybe water flowing through a stream and
the stream breaks in two and it's like
which way does the water go or something
goes one way somebody goes the other way
maybe it's uh maybe it depends in detail
whether that molecule was over towards
the left-hand side of the river or
towards the right-hand side of the river
and so on so i suspect that's the same
kind of thing with electrons and then as
the electrons go into the circuit
well gosh what will happen um
uh
let's see
i mean usually when you design a circuit
you imagine that there's kind of a
a rail which has a certain voltage which
has electrons that and then
you're kind of getting this whole thing
where you have two sort of a a
zero volts and a plus whatever is six
volts or something and you've got sort
of all the electrons are being dragged
through from one to the other but that
dragging through is through this whole
elaborate structure that is the circuit
that you're dealing with so i kind of
think it will be kind of like
uh you're kind of moving through this
whole collection of different um
different pieces of the circuit
now if you ask well what happens
yeah i think the most most significant
thing is the clock frequency of the
computer so what's going to happen is
every
um
the kind of okay electrons go move to
your next spots
that's going to happen
every time the the central clock of the
computer
uh has one sort of tick and so a typical
computer i don't know what the computer
that i'm using right now i would guess
it's a two gigahertz ish
clock
that means uh two billion times a second
the electrons get to
uh move to the next station so to speak
and so what's happening is like they
might be fixed okay you're in this
configuration okay now you move to the
next one it could take you a small
amount of time to move
the electrons don't move instantaneously
they move at a small a small fraction of
the speed of light through the wires i
think maybe
typically
i think maybe a tenth the speed of light
if i remember correctly
um i mean it depends on lots of lots of
different things but the so you know
when the clock says move the electrons
are going to move just a tiny bit
they're going to get stopped by some
gate somewhere and they're going to move
to the next position and then they're
going to be there then they'll wait
there then the clock ticks again then
they'll move to the next position and so
on and i think that's some uh that would
be kind of the picture of what's going
on now
um
uh and you know the whole logic of
what's happening in the circuit would be
sort of seen by the electron as oh
there's no voltage that's pulling me to
the next place i'm just going to sit
where i am for the time being i think
um so that that's that would be my my
basic picture of um
uh
um
yes m9 is pointing out field effect
transistors
use voltage at the gate to make a field
that pinches off the flow of current
from the drain to the source is it from
the joint to the source of the source of
the drain i think that's what we get for
having electrons have negative charge
that that's um uh yes that that's um
um
that's absolutely right and uh
if i think hard about this i could
probably tell you um in terms of of uh
how that works in terms of the doping of
semiconductors and so on of um but
that's that's the right the exactly the
right picture is you're kind of stopping
your your um uh you know
what's happening is
okay
let's see what's happening is
i have to think about this more
carefully that there are
um you can adjust
this band gap a bit
by having uh
impurities in the silicon crystal for
example
and uh you can have p type or n-type
impurities which are basically
uh
uh so silicon has valence for so silicon
has sort of four um four electrons that
are kind of available from each silicon
atom you can put in impurities that have
either three or five
uh electrons available
and those lead to a change
in
the uh amount of energy that you need to
give to an electron to reach this
conduction band
and
that's um and when you actually make a
circuit what you're doing is you're
putting
um now this is it's more complicated
than this
i
i have to think this through i've um
it's one of these things where uh
uh
when i i probably haven't thought about
this in a couple of decades so i can't
um i can't do it um uh
well instantly
um
it's uh
um
okay
and some
it's probably the best i can do for
right now
it looks like it's time for my my next
thing here but i see a lot of um
uh
um
a lot of interesting questions uh
which we can save up for next time and
um um
i'm
just um
thinking well i can say anything um
uh i i like this question of the
electron's view of uh of computation so
to speak um
and uh
um
i think
the um
the case of some kinds of things like in
a memory chip
um you know i think one will have a
situation where sort of electrons are
running around
uh kind of storing that one bit for one
um and then uh and then every so often
something will come in and and uh read
that bit and maybe that electron will be
like i've been storing that one bit
for the last two days and finally
something will come and take that
electron away and say okay you're going
to deliver your oneness so to speak to
some other part of the circuit and
another electron will come in and take
your pace place storing that one bit and
so on i think that's kind of might be
the electrons eye view of what's going
on i have to say i was i was curious
recently i need to get back to this i
was
in trying to understand sort of
questions about consciousness i was
trying to
kind of think about what is the
experience that a computer has i hadn't
gotten down to the level of what
experience an electron has that's an
interesting further level i was just
thinking about the experience that a
computer has of interacting with time
and and the outside world and so on
anyway i think to talk about another
time maybe i'll talk about that another
time here could help me kind of collect
my thoughts about um the uh what how a
computer consciousness
kind of
feels about the world
right well thanks very much lots of
interesting questions um
uh
i enjoyed trying to think some of these
things through
um and uh
this is a i have to say
it's an interesting for me
these uh these live streams are an
interesting uh
um
kind of experience because
you know i'm trying to answer these
questions sort of in real time without
any outside
you know
uh information
and um uh these are and and trying to um
uh trying to sort of piece together some
of these more complicated things
uh it's often the worst when it's
something which i think i've understood
for decades but i don't think i've ever
explained it to anybody um and helps me
a lot to actually have this opportunity
to uh to explain it even though it's a
little bit
um i make it a bit more difficult for
myself by insisting on just trying to
say it directly
rather than you know thinking for a a a
long time about kind of how to arrange
the pieces but so i hope what what i'm
communicating is useful it's um as i say
it's helpful to me in in um
in being able to collect my thoughts i i
think for example today i talked about a
number of things to do with programmable
matter that i don't think i've ever
really put together in quite those ways
before so um thanks for inducing me to
do that
and uh well
see you again another time